hey Conan O'Brien here with another
clueless gamer it's been a while since
we've done one of these some say too
long I say just the right amount of time
but we're back and better than ever
joining me as always Aaron Blair or as
we call him blay
explain what we're doing today today
we're not playing through a console
we're playing through a Samsung
television this OLED Samsung television
has uh the Samsung gaming Hub and we're
going to be playing some Xbox games
straight through the TV we're playing
through the TV that's right ah well they
never stop innovating we're going right
through the television the only reason I
play video games and I think the reason
most people play video games is to shoot
something just something I want to shoot
something yes is there a game where I
can fire away I've got it it's called
Death Loop and I like this because it
has a has a fun Jazzy soundtrack well
when I'm playing a video game my first
question is does it have a cool Jazz
soundtrack so I'm now my name is Jack
death Loop you said no the cult if the
game's called Death Loop my name should
be Jack death Loop and who am I fighting
so you're just gonna you're killing all
these eternalists who don't want the
loop to be broken there you go yeah
yeah yeah wait what happened oh it's
okay you come back to life I can't die
yeah I'm coked definitely I'm gonna get
better at this you'll see oh
oh that was awesome eat some death have
a death sandwich on me
oh my God yeah there's a death buffet
and there's extra eggs benedict
okay what happened I thought I was doing
pretty well there you're doing great
you're killing them all because this gun
also make pasta
I will kill you and then I'll make a
tortellini a feta Genie now we're gonna
play one of my favorite games power wash
simulator this is all about uh cleaning
stuff wait the game is now we're going
to clean a car yeah and after this we're
gonna play fix that toilet seven
thousand there you go you just want to
clean the whole thing you go up and down
with the right stick the right stick
goes up in there you got different
nozzles if you want to hit the top
buttons uh I don't understand it's why
most people playing this game are doing
it in their filthy apartment that they
refuse to clean Milton
and virtually cleaning a car I don't own
for no money this is my scenario all
right okay I just committed a terrible
series of murders
and I uh I managed to get rid of the
bodies but there's blood everywhere all
over my van I'm looking out the window
I'm gonna make sure that no one's around
nice nosy neighbors don't they mind
their own goddamn business
maybe I should pay Mrs Henderson a visit
tomorrow use that later to get rid of
the bodies
I got the shovel put the heads in there
there you go
and there's the beach chair so I can go
to the beach to relax okay blay what's
next so this next game is called a
plague tale Requiem it's a sequel to a
play Tale in a sense it takes place in
1349 and you are amacia and uh you uh
your little brother Hugo has come down
with an illness uh called the macula
which is a supernatural evil that's it
because there's a Magister there I named
Verdin who we think uh can help us he's
one of those who starts uh we're gonna
start in the game where we've just uh
the road to Province and we're kind of
on the run but you know not really uh we
think that he can help us cure uh you
know killed a couple evil beekeepers and
now we're on the plague which is
spreading uh across France one thing
I've learned and this is after years and
years of doing these with you is not to
ask about evil beekeepers okay not to
ask about any of the [ __ ] you just
spouted basically what you're saying is
this is a game that simulates what it's
like to live during a play yes even
though we've just lived through two and
a half years of covid you now want to
play a game where we walk around
and try not to get sick
yes so this is a game about Stealth so
they can't see us when we're in the in
the grass like this right I like any
game where I'm a coward
creeping around in the grass
just stay low don't do anything don't
fight anybody just keep creeping in the
tall grass all right
perfect well good more Tall Grass I can
hide and do nothing right trigger run to
the house welcome to Tall Grass The
Runaway game
where you avoid all danger by laying low
yeah there you go you got to save your
mother you have to save your mother
relationship
okay so okay left trigger she's being
held hosted that's my mother yeah hold
the left trigger what's the right
trigger that's the right trigger right
she's gonna die wait you see it killed
her but wait a minute wait a minute
first of all a couple of things I have
complicated feelings about my mother
which interfered with my actions there's
a lot of love there but there's also
some anger okay some [ __ ] went down in
the mid 70s and I'm still not cool with
okay and now we're with Lucas uh who's
just our friend he's a family friend
uh-oh
oh a fellow coward
oh good I like this guy please don't
hurt me don't worry we just want Tall
Grass too we all wish to hide in the
grass
oh no
what's this
oh no rats that's a stupid amount of
rats a stupid amount of rats oh no you
gotta run you gotta run all right
oh no I went into the rats why did I go
into the rats that's right run away from
the rats open run this run this way from
the rat there you go you're doing it
you're doing it no no Run keep running
this way what happened I went as fast
you're running against the wall
what's wrong with that you didn't say
Don't run against the wall it slows you
it slows you down yeah but rats don't
like a wall it's their natural enemy
stop handing me the control and then
yelling at me when things don't go well
I feel like you hey little boy take over
for this 747 in a storm what did you do
okay now we're gonna go through the rats
yeah it's an unrealistic number of rats
rat to defeat all these rats this is
voyologically impossible back rats back
this is me dealing with comedy writers
foreign
you'll get paid when I'm ready to pay
you back racks back
okay so this part so valdan began to
study Hugo's sickness but his treatment
led the boy to have a seizure wait he
was treated and he had a seizure yeah he
would sue the doctor yeah that's what
you do yeah that's when the real rats
come out the lawyers
Zing comment on how we need tort reform
okay okay
you didn't think you'd hear a tort
reform argument for me that's what I
think when I see those rats
that's a lot of rats okay so we're gonna
run from the rats you're gonna run
towards us when we get get up here we go
run okay oh run away I mean run away
okay no not towards us I'm in a way I'm
in a way
why did you not do anything because I
was trying to give you the thing I'm
busy doing this there's not this is to
create a more of a realistic game
experience here you go here you go
forward and right trigger forward and
right trick
you can't can't
laughs
you wait until rats are crawling up my
anus and then you hand me the controller
[Music]
okay once again we had a lot of fun and
learned nothing check out Samsung gaming
TVs at samsung.com gaming TVs or at
participating
retailers look I'm a rat